[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are in the middle of busy
videogame season and new games are
dropping like leaves at least if it's
fall in your part of the world but it's
just about November everywhere so this
episode of new releases is gonna cover
another full month of games tune in next
week for the usual weekly dose of the
show but for now let's take a look at
some of November's biggest titles and it
doesn't get much bigger than Call of
Duty World War two's mission is pretty
clear from the name it's going back to
the series roots in the European theater
all the crazy futuristic jetpacks and
robots are in the past this campaign
focuses on the first division and
they're comparatively limited arsenal
one where you'll actually have to seek
out ammo and health packs to keep
yourself stocked that said you can still
expect the same level of competition
from multiplayer with maps from all
sorts of fronts not seen in the story
can't forget about nazi zombies co-op
either Call of Duty World War two
deploys on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
November 3rd by this point pretty much
everyone knows what Sonic games are all
about but sonic forces is looking to mix
things up in a few ways first the
classic and modern hedgehogs both return
from generations letting them run
through 2d and 3d levels respectively
joining them is well whoever you want to
join them for the first time you can
build your own character to race through
Sonic levels and depending on the base
you choose your custom hero will have
special abilities to use along the way
you can try it for yourself on ps4 Xbox
one PC and Nintendo switch Tuesday
November 7th and if you want to see an
action before then we've got gameplay at
both regular roll sonic and our custom
character up on GameSpot no promises on
anymore you know messages though don't
use a building for canvas because that
speaking of games that go really fast
let's talk about Need for Speed payback
much like Sonic you probably already
know what the Need for Speed games are
all about but this entry takes big
influences from The Fast and Furious
movies with an open world ready for what
publisher EA calls action driving you've
got three drivers with different skills
behind the wheel and you'll have to use
them all to take down the house a cartel
that runs the underworld in Fortune
Valley you can start your engines on ps4
Xbox one and PC on Friday November 10
and now for something more kid-friendly
Lego Marvel Super Heroes to UPS the
minifigure ante the only way it can with
a collision of multiple Marvel
Universe's you'll be able to explore a
bunch of different worlds like a noir
version of New York nowhere and an
alternate medieval timeline as you chase
after crying the Conqueror with
colliding worlds comes all sorts of
crazy characters - including
combinations like iron duck that's
that's Howard the Duck Plus iron man yep
in any case you can start building on
ps4 Xbox one PC and Nintendo switch on
Tuesday November 14th now how about
something for kids and adults because no
matter which Star Wars era you prefer
battlefront 2 covers it all maps draw
from the original prequel and sequel
trilogies with a brand new single-player
story mode featuring original characters
and all future maps and heroes DLC will
be free for you too let's not forget the
large scale space ship battles either
you can strap in and take off into those
on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
November 17 and those are some of the
hottest games we'll be playing all month
long as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with your
usual weekly episode of new releases
next Sunday